跟老公是亲戚介绍认识的嘛，
然后交往半年之后意外怀孕了一年结了婚，
然后跟刚生了一个女儿，
我现在六个月了，
我跟他是同年，
也是30岁，
普通家庭，
然后爸妈没有退休金了，
有两个弟弟，
但是都已经结婚，
我在一三线城市工作，
现在呃，
月薪五六千一个月吧，
我自己的呃，
十万的存款，
婚前我买了一辆车，
但是车现在我娘家人在用，
异弟就还月购买，
这是我出的首付。
我老公是是30岁，
是独生子，
当过兵，
然后他跟我在一起的时候没有稳定工作后，
现在也没有稳定工作，
他父母都有退休金的，
然后他家在三线城市买了一套房，
我国付的首付没月供，
现在是8000多一个月，
那月供也基本都是婆婆在还，
伯婆是自己做了一点生意，
但是如果婆婆的生意合同到期的话，
这个房贷估计是还不起的啦，
就是刚跟他认识的时候，
中间是隔一两年没有联系的，
就是联系之后才慢慢谈，
然后才结婚的，
因为他将买的房啊，
离我上班的。
然后很近，
然后家我没多久她装修了，
男朋友他妈就一直叫我搬去他家住，
我就是不好意思拒绝，
然后不懂拒绝呀，
住了，
我是有乙干嘛，
然后因为我有肝这件事，
我很自卑，
一直不敢交男朋友，
怕对方嫌弃我是乙肝，
在我得自自乙肝之前，
我没有发生过关系，
就是我妈妈也有嘛，
可能是我妈那是老一辈的，
他们对这方面知识没有那么多的夫及吧，
也不懂啊，
农村的。
在我跟我男朋友要发生关系，
我是不同意，
然后我就跟他坦白了，
我说我有一单，
然后他说不介意，
就放宽心下来了，
然后去他家，
是我没说我有干之前是他就愿意跟我睡，
到后面我跟他坦白我干这件事之后，
他就说分房睡，
他刚开始找了一份工，
说要调整休息，
怕影响我上班，
然后我也没有在意什么的嘛，
我也接受，
就是后面怀孕了，
结婚了。
就是一直分房睡到现在，
没结婚当天也不睡婚房那种，
没结婚之前就同居嘛，
然后有一次跟他离这个事情，
他跟我冷暴力异郁了十几天，
然后那时候想分手的时候发现自己怀孕了，
然后他爸妈还有他也是说愿意跟我结婚那种嘛，
等我就是又跟他说要去我家拜访我家人的时候，
他跟我坦白了一件事，
说他可能感染了。
六六对，
他就跟我坦白的说，
他可能感染，
因为他自己买那个试剂嘛，
他之前有不长。
说他去酒吧喝多了后，
你现在就告诉我结果是什么，
他真的感染了吗？
后面他去抽血，
他没有感，
他染，
我那时候喝了就接，
不想要小孩了，
然后最后替他了这件单也没有忍心去，
因为他说这件事不要告诉他的父母，
我就是很厉害问你啊，
他说的不聊那个什么行为，
指的是他跟目前的女性发生那个亲密行为，
还是跟男性发生亲密行为？
这个我不清楚，
我坦白的是说是去酒吧，
酒吧那个工作的女性发生了关系是吗？
对。
他说是没跟我在一起之前，
其实是在跟我在一起交往期间，
他发生的事情也还算他有点良心，
他可以直接告诉你，
他有可能得HIV，
他也在纠结要不要告诉我，
他也问了其他的人，
然后人家就说你还是坦白嘛，
然后他才跟我坦白，
他因为跟我坦白这件事，
我还觉得他有点良心嘛，
你想要龙子律师帮你解答的问题是什么？
我想继续说一下我的她大概目前的一个情况，
我以为她因为这件事他会改嘛，
我怀疑孕期之间我发现她包里还有那种润滑剂，
给我的感觉就是她还是有这种行为，
我很内耗啊，
我平时跟他相处吧，
就是两个在屋檐下，
她就喜欢爱熬夜什么，
有时候晚上也不回来，
我打电话也有时候爱接不接，
打视频他也说我他不喜欢接视频什么的。
在我。
生孩子的当天，
她陪我住院，
到我进了产房，
从上午到下午没有生。
下午我要剖腹产了，
要需要她签字。
她不在医院，
只有她爸妈在外面，
他说跑出去跟一个老总办事去了。
还有就是在我做月子的时候，
他也出钱，
但是不是出全部钱，
就是一半钱他出我去的月子中心，
半是我自己出。
现在希望龙飞律师帮你解答的问题是，
你该不该跟这个人继续下去，
那我明确的告诉你好不好？
答案我告诉你好不好，
嗯。
嗯，
我觉得我们女人来这世上一辈子，
首先我们要对自己的身体健康负责任，
我现在是跟她分房睡，
我现在也不跟他一起睡，
对呀，
我也有抵触心理，
不过你都已经跟他分房了，
你都已经跟他有抵触心理了，
有什么必要跟他继续在一起呢？
就是看在小孩养小的份上，
把生活习惯很不好，
内裤袜子衣服都放在一个洗衣期里面洗，
说了也是一样不听，
觉得你和小孩跟他生活在一起，
万一他哪天真的得了呢？
如果你今天问我说龙飞律师这个人会改吗？
那我给你的答案就是我不愿意，
我不愿意拿我自己的生命和健康，
拿我女儿的生命和健康去赌外面另外一个人会不会改，
因为另外一个人会不会改，
他是我们无法掌控的因素，
理解了吗？
因为现在基本所么小孩的那些尿布啊，
都是婆婆出钱，
我要带自己小孩的话比小，
我婆家那边的话，
我弟媳啊也有小孩，
我妈也需要带个婆婆果我想问的是，
因为小孩还小，
因为他家可能经济比我家好一点嘛，
如果小孩跟他的话，
可能上的学会比我去带小孩每年家上的学校会好一点，
我考虑的就是这一点，
比你想问我的问题是，
如果你我几个人分开，
要不要带小孩走，
是这意思吗？
就是我带小孩走，
然后的时。
我要怎么过？
我，
我让小孩跟婆就是婆婆，
公公是人，
很好的人，
但是老公不行。
啊，
这个事情呢，
你自己，
嗯，
能出去工作了，
我现在工作让婆婆帮衬着带着，
什么时候你自己足够强大了，
你带着孩子也能过得很好了，
再做这个决定，
现在你在外面工作，
婆婆也帮你带着孩子是吧，
就先这样，
等什么时候你足够强大了，
工作挺好的了，
你有这个能力带着孩子过了再做这个决定，
现在先不要做这个决定啊，
就是我带着小孩的话，
真的会累了，
我妈，
因为他要带。
家里面第媳一个小孩，
他也要把我带，
小孩年龄差不多就相差一岁，
这样为了你和孩子的健康，
为了你和孩子的生命安全，
离开他是一个确定的结果，
至于什么时候能离开他，
就看你什么时候自己的工作比较稳定了，
收入也比较稳定了，
有了一定的经济基础了，
自己攒一点四方米了，
不好这个准备了，
开的时候要不要带孩子，
也取决于你离开的时候自己的经济状况和你的能力就是怎么平衡，
就比如说小孩子他以后的上学就是上学条件，
我的话就只能回娘家，
是在校内，
乡镇的嘛，
就生活环境很好，
但是可能教育啊就不比他们家好，
反正现在的这个出生率大家都知道，
出生率不是很高，
所以孩子想进好一点的学校，
现在也没有那么难，
就不管在哪里，
孩子想进好一点的学校也没有那么难了，
因为我自己心里有个打算，
就是可能旁观者就清一点，
就想让旁观者帮我分析分析，
其实我自己心里面也有一个问题呢，
我最后我是get到了，
就是一个如果女生的是。
这个小女孩，
如果小女孩的爸爸是属于那种特别不着调，
哎，
有可能发生一些不健康的啊心理行为，
我觉得这个小女孩跟着爸爸的话，
从我这个角度来看的话，
始终是有隐患的，
这个大家能接受吗？
就是一个小女孩跟着这样一个啊不着调儿的爸爸，
且容易在外面发生不健康的那个行为的爸爸，
跟她生活在一起的话，
我认为是有隐患的，
那两害相权取其亲，
如果跟着妈妈生活在一起，
只是生活条件差一点，
教育水平差一点，
和跟着爸爸在一起会存在其他方面的隐患，
这两件事情比起来的话，
小女孩可能还是跟着妈妈的幸福指数更高一点。
这个大家能接受吗？
龙飞姐分析的这个逻辑也尤其是如果说跟爸爸生活在一起，
将来爸爸再娶一个老婆，
对吧？
相当于孩子要跟后妈在一个屋檐下去生活在这里。
龙飞律是并没有觉得后妈就一定不好，
但是我前段时间看到一个极端的案例，
对我心里造成了很大的冲击，
那都不是后妈，
那是前夫找了一个女朋友，
本来女方和男方离婚了啊，
那个分手了啊，
孩子是归女方带，
女方自己孩子也带到3岁多了啊，
很乖巧很听话的一个小男孩儿。
然后前夫呢，
就以什么理由和借口想要带孩子呢？
前夫以说什么爷爷奶奶生病了啊，
说想要看看孙子，
以这样一个借口来找这个前妻，
想要把这个小孩再去看看爷爷奶奶，
这个前妻心软了嘛，
觉得爷爷奶奶可能人还不错啊，
就让孩子跟着她前夫去看看爷爷奶奶，
结果这一走，
这前夫就带着孩子就消失了，
就拉黑了，
这个妈妈带着孩子就不知道带孩子去哪儿了，
后来这个前夫又找了个女朋友，
这个妈妈都跟疯了一样，
找8个月，
8个月之后。
接到了医院的电话，
医院电话是干嘛的？
这孩子已经不行了，
要去拔管，
等他去的时候，
这孩子听到妈妈的声音，
只知道掉眼泪，
已经睁不开眼睛，
没有办法跟妈妈互动了。
大概在那个。
待了个六七天，
七八天，
孩子还是没保住，
但是孩子浑身都是伤，
里里外外全都是新伤加旧伤，
他是被带，
被他前夫的女朋友虐虐带的。
就看到这些极端的案例了之后，
我就联想到这个案例当中，
如果爸爸是那么不着调的人，
你能寄希望于爸爸以后再找一个老婆，
是一个很好很善良，
很对你的女儿特别好的一个女人吗？
你敢去这么堵吗？
我的姐妹，
所以就如果说跟着妈妈只是生活上吃点苦啊，
或者说教育水平上没有那么高啊，
总比放在爸爸那里有那么大的隐患，
有那么多的不可控的因素，
那个风险要小很多了。
就这意思啊，
我刚刚连麦的这个妹妹啊，
我个人觉得你自己能够学习一下怎么跟女儿相处啊，
你尤其是不能把自己命运当中的这些遇到的不好的事情宣泄到女儿身上，
也不能说啊，
因为妈妈带着你，
妈妈又不能再嫁一个好男人了，
或者妈妈又不能再找一个好工作了，
或者妈妈因为带上你妈妈的生活水平下降了，
你不能把你的负面情绪施加给你的女儿。
我说这话是不是有点多余啊，
有点太操心了。
因为现实生活中真的有很多妈妈把自己的负面情绪就是宣泄给孩子的，
就是觉得自己啊，
拖这个孩子不好嫁人了，
拖这个孩子不好找工作了，
拖这个孩子的生活水平下降了，
没有自己的时间了，
然后把自己的对生活中的很多的不满，
很多的不如意全都编卸到小孩的身上，
小孩他那么一个小小的身体，
你可能对他吼一次，
对他凶一次，
对他有一次情绪的宣泄，
于他而言的话，
就整个天都塌了。